And they had a six figure job and I was the stay at home mom.
This is what happened to me.
So I'm just telling everyone of you,
if you are a stay at home parent,
don't do it. Or if you are,
make sure that you get paid a salary by your ex.
Put into an account for you.
Because I'm telling you right now,
they will just up in one day,
17 years later, decide that they don't wanna do anything anymore.
After you supported their career
and you supported their dreams and hobbies,
one day they might just wake up and say, oh,
I don't wanna do this anymore.
And then you're homeless, single parent, um,
just trying to survive. I no longer have insurance on this house.
This house is. Isn't even mine.
Both of my parents died in the last year
and I've been staying in their house.
Like the electric bills, not even in my name.
I had to go this morning and pay the past due Bill
so they wouldn't cut it off.
I work on the weekends, I work through the week.
I am not making enough money.
I am trying. I'm disabled.
I was a stay at home mom for 14 years.
I haven't had a job interview outside of the home in 20 years.
Um, I am literally doing my best.
I am drowning in debt, in, uh, depression,
in trauma. My ex sends me abusive text
when I try To ask for anything to be done about the child support
for them to parent.
There will never be consequences for them ruining my credit
because they don't pay what is court ordered.
There just never will be. And I know I'm bitching.
I'm bitching, I don't care.
I'm bitching because it's not fair.
And lots of women go through this
and it's disgusting and sick and something should be done.